Freedom means being able to find out the
truth and share it with the World Press
Freedom means we're able to do our jobs
freely and independently that we're able
to ask tough questions tell important
stories and hold the powerful to account
all without fear of censorship or
intimidation to be able to go home and
be with my family
and not worry about being kidnapped or
beat up or killed press freedom is vital
when covering Russia's invasion of
Ukraine if people so understand what's
happening on the ground especially
because there are so many state and
non-state actors involved and when
propaganda is often used by both sides
I've been reporting on civil strife and
abuse of power in Latin America for over
30 years challenging those who'd rather
we keep quiet doesn't get any easier
that's why freedom of the press matters
it's the ability to report the news
without fear of being killed film
without fear of getting shots and right
without fear of being sentenced to jail
it's free movement and right to
information that those in power don't
want you to know press Freedom means
being able to report the facts without
fear of being reprimanded by authorities
and not having to constantly worry that
anything I say could be construed in any
other way than what I'm reporting press
Freedom means having the ability to
question authority without consequence
it's a protected right in the United
States but it's something that even here
is becoming increasingly difficult it's
knowing that all the hard work that we
put in here across the world and across
our Network senses is getting to where
it needs to be thus taking the voice of
those that are helpless and giving it to
those who can offer the help